how's the screenwriting market changed
over the course of your writing career
the screenwriting market has definitely
changed people don't really buy
treatments anymore like they used to
they really want the whole script and
they don't pay as much as they used to
the sales are different like I there are
definitely those times when people get
that you've heard of a million dollars
for a script or whatever I don't you
don't hear those stories anymore maybe
we'll hear them again in the future I
don't know but you really don't hear
those stories anymore and also it's
changed because screenwriters I think
have gotten more independent in their
spirit and their thoughts about things
so screenwriters now want a part of the
pie in a different way they want to be
producers on it or somehow be connected
to it other than just selling the script
and being gone they don't really want to
do that anymore
it used to be you could just sell your
script and you're not even invited to
the set you know you can come to the
premiere but you know I think a lot of
writers want to be more involved in the
entire process maybe I'm wrong with that
I don't think so and maybe it's because
I'm in the indie world a lot so there's
a lot of all tours you know writer
directors writer producers you know or
maybe that's just the way that you get
your movie made as a writer you have to
find a producer and help find elements
to make it happen you know interesting
right rather than just being this like
and then you read about in the trades
and yeah yeah
Shane black or it's bright if you are
connected in that way then sometimes it
can happen I know some screenwriters
like some actors transition into
screenwriting there's like a lot of ways
that different things happen and there's
definitely screen TV writers who become
you know film writers you know I think
JJ Abrams started out in television or
did he start I think he did start out in
TV transition the film but still does
amazing TV and film now so he you know
there's just a lot of different ways
okay
and then lastly I think you talked about
how do you think it's harder though
today because because there's so many
people doing it right there's so many
people doing it it's harder but maybe
there's a lot more possibility because
there's so many different mediums and
there's so many different channels and
people really actually do need product
and material so it's it's a catch-22 and
a little it's a battle it balances
itself out there's more opportunities
and possibilities in a certain way but
it's still harder to really break in to
have a solid solid solid career if that
makes any sense it does I mean I can
think of people that I've known that
I've done commercials right years ago
and they made more money and they were
sort of that person and then now it's so
flooded and the money is not the same
it's not right you know a buyout or
something and and and that's the thing
about being a now it's like this you
know the infamous you know the gate key
the walls are down from the gatekeepers
and all right and so now everyone's
doing it and the good part is that it's
accessible to everyone the bad part is
everybody's doing it right it's - Mary
how did
you